alorso c'est la samba on va aller
danser sur un air brésilien thomascher
perform pour la Journée internationale
de la samba j'inle la
musique pas trop
fort une très bonne
dorseuse un peu plus fort on peut mettre
un peu plus
fort
[Musique]
voil
[Applaudissements]
bougez la samba samedi ça fait un truc
la samba pas pour moi ah bon non vous
êtes quoi
vous hop là hop là j'essaie de suivre
c'est très dur
[Musique]
allez allez allez les
filles
je on va voir les
KPI c'est très bon hein PL oua c'est
très très bon c'est le meilleur des
Yvelines c'est he c'est le meilleur des
evel c'est la meilleure des Eveline la C
PIR c'est la meilleure de Paris de Paris
de France meilleur du Brésil vous voulez
que je lui
apporte Elisa s'il vous plaît merci
beaucoup il y a un ingrédient secret
utiliseer une bonne cach àa ok ouais et
ça c'est la meilleure celle que vous
avez
là oh là oui mais on a a mieux il y a
mieux ok ça c'est la sublime kachasa qui
est la kachasa artisanale d'accord c'est
du R ou
quoi oh là là qui fait la meilleure KP
de la famille là ah je sais pas ça stat
ça St ouais oh parce que moi moi moi
quand j'en fais une mais moi c'est la
mienne moi tout le monde me juge mais
moi je mets la 12 ouis larme il y a
beaucoup de larmes
es triste bonjour Alby ça va ça va et
vous Albi il fait quoi samedi tu fais
quoi samedi toi pour la je travaille
genre vous voulez goûter un pain au
fromage ok en portugais s'appelle les PA
pa c'est très bon vachement bon au
Brésil il Mang ça avec le café le matin
et vous faites un truc pour samedi la
journée de la samba sinon c'est au
Brésil par demain ah ouais vous allez
danser là-bas alors so vous croyez pas
on peut venir ou ouais on peut venir je
montrer parcear Croz pas on y croit pas
ce pouvez nous l'envoyer le billet merde
c'est où les trucs il l'a pas en fait B
il mon mais non si vous montez il est
làte bleu est
[Musique]
là un
Ry 7
8 on fait quoi des mains tu les laisses
pour l'instant ok ta main sur l'omoplate
5 6 7 8 et on regarde avec amour bien
sûr et on est à l'aise toujours ça va tu
es à l'aise non onomence gauche vas-y
sur place sur place derrière derrière
sur place merde sur place vas-y vas-y je
on recommence sur place derrière allez
on sourit on est heureux on est
heureux et tac tac l' que 7 et tac tac
le step je ma tête on sourit pas fatigé
j
ouais ok alors je t'ai pas demandé de me
toucher le
derrière sur le
[Musique]
côté